welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and what's the bigger threat to
America a bunch of pro wrestlers dressed
as snakes or a billionaire who thinks
he's the hero forcing us to see reality
through his virtual lens so that we
forget about everything bad he did and
elect him as mayor or president
obviously it's a pro wrestlers dress as
snakes get them out of here despite
Marvel studios's New Year's resolution
to avoid extensive reshoots on upcoming
films I guess it's actually going to be
starting next year because Captain
America Brave New World has been deemed
too crucial to screw up perhaps due to
the sensitive nature of Sam Wilson as
Captain America or Hollywood Legend
Harrison Ford in the cast or just the
implications of past titles New World
Order and having a character like Sabra
in the plot but this film is reportedly
undergoing several months of re-shoot in
fact a new production period that most
Hollywood films are budgeted for their
entire principal shooting lasting and
among these changes are rumors that they
are dropping the serpent society as the
low tier Act One villain on the level of
like crossbones of Civil War bat Rock
and Captain americ Winter Soldier in
re-shooting some key action sequences so
we may actually be looking at a very
different version of the this movie and
based on new clues that have emerged in
Daredevil Born Again production Marvel
Studios may be reshaping their whole
broader narrative around the political
gravity of Kingpin so to be clear while
I think Harrison for adius Ross Red Hulk
will still be the villain of this fourth
Captain America movie I think one of the
influences that will drive him to that
extreme at least after these re-shoot
will be Wilson Fisk in his digital
misinformation campaign assisted by some
allies from past MCU eras a fake news
Alliance that prays upon a uniquely
confused populace that is now living in
this trauma MCU by the way new rockstars
is doing a live show in Los Angeles on
Thursday February 15th at brain dead
Studios where you can join us in person
to talk about the big news we're going
to learn from the Super Bowl trailers
and to see us do some stuff that we
never get to do here on YouTube tickets
are still available Link in the
description below okay let's talk about
what Captain America 4 was going to be
before these recent changes a fourth
Captain America movie was green lit in
2021 coming out of the Falcon the Winter
Soldier following Sam Wilson as Captain
America at San Diego ComicCon in July
2022 the film's title was announced as
Captain America new world World Order
taking its name from the premiere
episode of the Falcon the Winter Soldier
and this movie was assigned to director
Julius Ona the film was slated to be the
final film of phase five of the MCU so
presumably Kevin feige and his team
viewed it as a kind of climactic Koda
the cast was announced as Anthony Mackey
as Sam Wilson Captain America Danny
Ramirez coming back from the Falcon the
Winter Soldier as walking tourus now
Falcon Carl lumbley as Isaiah Bradley
and Tim Blake Nelson returning from the
2008 Incredible Hulk film as Samuel
Sterns aka the leader and Shir Hass was
also announced joining the cast as Sabra
a character from Marvel Comics with ties
to the Israeli mosad yep then in Fall
2022 we learned that Harrison Ford was
joining the cast as Thaddius Ross
replacing the late William Herz and that
Thaddius Ross will now be the American
president in this movie production for
this film began in March 2023 and we
learned that Liv Tyler would be
returning as Betty Ross and that Julia
Lou dfus would join the cast this was
after we learned that Val is the mcu's
current director of the CIA as a black
panther W kind of forever and in June
2023 the film was reportedly wrapped on
production and renamed captain America
Brave New World in 2023 we learned that
pro wrestler Seth Rollins was going to
be part of this cast and on December on
the other side of the labor strikes Rosa
Salazar was announced to be part of the
film and at this point the previous
version of the film had wrapped and the
release date was moved to February 14th
2025 the movie was in post-production
Cuts were being shown to test audiences
and Rumor Has It their reactions were
not good some said that the film's major
action sequences were underwhelming and
reportedly three of the movie sequences
were being cut but I think people read
that on social media and they don't
really know what that means like what is
a sequence is it like an entire battle
scene not necessarily because in
cinematic terms a sequence really refers
to a string of interconnected scenes in
a film that really amount to like one
narrative movement like you may hear
about the eight sequences on every
screenplay but that's like screenplay
structure when we're talking about
production of a typical film we're
talking about somewhere between 20 to 30
total sequences in a film and in a
Marvel film that could be especially
hard to quantify because action
sometimes spills over from one sequence
to another sequence so like an entire
battle can take up an entire Act of a
movie in the MCU but like for example in
Captain America Civil War really a
single sequence would be like Bucky and
Sam side tussle with Spider-Man in the
interior of the terminal of the airport
battle not the entire airport battle a
sequence you know it just kind of refers
to a sizable chunk that you could
extract if it's not contributing
anything meaningful to the overall act
ideally everything would be contributing
something though but basically you can
remove a sequence without throwing the
baby out with a bath water still in
Captain America Brave New World here's
what we suspect was part of the original
movies plot Sam Wilson as Captain
America in a conflict with like an
especially aggressive us
military-industrial complex Harrison
Ford as president thadius Ross and
potentially a red Hulk storyline that
could tie to Samuel Sterns as the leader
and Hulk blood a plot that generally
involves misinformation and conspiracy
theories and then perhaps the death of a
major character because we saw some
funeral set photos and an opening battle
with the serpent society that could
include Rosa Salazar and Seth Rollins so
the serpent Society refers to a group of
snake themed super villains who actually
first appeared in Captain America comics
in 1985 but were later renamed serpent
Solutions when they appeared in Captain
America Sam Wilson number one in 2015
this is the run from Nick Spencer and
Daniel Akuna that has most inspired this
era of Sam Wilson in the MCU Rosa
Salazar was speculated to be playing
diamond back from the serpent Society it
was believed that the serpent society
would be working for Samuel Sterns but
if you remember the serpent Society was
actually used as a fake out villain when
Kevin feige unveiled the phase three
slate back in October 2014 initially
announcing Captain America 3 as Captain
America serpent Society before revealing
that title as a red herring and then
bringing out Robert Danny Jr on the
stage to declare that it would actually
be Captain America Civil War so now I
think when people heard serpent Society
they thought wait a minute you mean that
organization that Marvel used as a joke
title in 2014 are we supposed to take
this seriously really I think it was
expected that the serpent Society in
Captain America 4 would be kind of like
an opening sequence of combatant kind of
like batrick the leapers group in
Captain America Winter Soldier and Brock
rumo crossbones in the opening act of
Civil War but you know looking back
between those guys and Hydra being
thwarted in the opening act of Age of
Ultron does it kind of feel like Marvel
Studios is leaving some of the more
potentially interesting villain groups
on the table and not exploring them as
much as they could I think that is
really the adjustment Marvel Studios may
be feeling internally when they've taken
long hard looks at all of these projects
they may feel like they're wasting some
of the elements from the comics and they
may just feel like they need to be more
economical about this and not treat
every villainous entity from the Marvel
Comics as one and done I think it's
interesting that this transition is
occurring around the same time that
Marvel ordered almost a complete
re-shoot of the Daredevil Born Again
series and this was right after Ekko
released and ekko's episodes were also
restructured to place a heavy emphasis
on Vincent denafo Wilson Fisk in fact
that series post-edit scene ended with
him planning to meet with other quote
remaining heads of some organization and
plotting a run for mayor a bare knuckled
brawler would do well in this race an
outsider somebody who is not afraid to
take on the establishment but wouldn't
that candidate have emerged by now
that's the the question that remains for
so many people is that candidate even
out there set photos from Daredevil
bornn again included a newspaper
headline reporting fisk's candidacy
alongside an interesting headline about
the metaverse here's a little inside
baseball for you new rock stars loves
dogs the lineup includes Darla Hank
Bubba Jeff Tilda they're just as much as
part of the family as I don't know our
spreadsheet guy he probably has a name
anyhow if you love your dog you know how
important it is to make sure they're
happy and healthy that's why once we
started using Sundays for dogs we
haven't touched other dog foods Sundays
is a fresh dog food made from a short
list of human great ingredients it's 90%
meat 10% vegetables and 0% synthetic
nutrients since giving our dogs Sundays
we've noticed a ton of improvements with
their health softer fur fresher breath
better poops and more energy Sundays
doesn't require refrigeration or
Preparation because it's air dried you
can just pour and serve and if you're
taking your dog on the road or on a trip
it's super easy to take some with you
and it's super easy to get every order
of Sundays ships right to your door so
you never have to worry about running
out get 50% off your first order of
Sundays go to Sundays for dogs.com neww
rockstars or use the code new rockstars
at check out I actually recently chatted
with head riter of eeko Marian dare you
can watch the full interview over on the
breakroom Channel and Marian revealed
that Kingpin is now being established to
have some tech Engineers working for him
in ways that we didn't see before on the
Netflix series yeah and he's got like
technology companies doesn't he so like
also he's developing new products that
he hopes can be all over the world so
maybe there's like a Fisk line of
technology that he's interested in we
also talked about the possibility that
Maya Lopez's finishing move might have
healed Wilson Fisk in some creepy
problematic way she holds her hands to
his head are we supposed to feel like
she is healing something in him in that
moment what do you what did you feel I
felt that she was um I felt that like
you know that rabbit in a sow snowstorm
component to kingpen is so important to
him from the Netflix show where he's
looking at the wall as his U father's
abusing his mom and like for Ekko to go
back in his bedroom with him it felt
like wow we are we're starting to fix
something in Kingpin in that moment and
I don't know if like I'm kind of scared
to see what happens where he feels like
he's healing because I I don't know I I
want to villainize him you know yes that
that was perfect I mean I I wasn't
leading you into an answer but I but I
feel like you know that's the hope is
that uh people will internalize it just
the way that you did and ask themselves
the same kind of questions and what does
that mean for him those are questions
that we hoped uh we could set up for
people is like
who is
Kingpin uh without that those feelings I
don't know yeah yeah Maran Dar is
confirming that that isn't like a
healing to turn Wilson Fisk into a good
guy it's something far worse it makes
him think in his head that he's a good
guy when he's still just as bad as he's
always been so I believe what we are now
seeing is a new era of Wilson Fisk as a
very interesting big bad of the MCU and
it's why we keep hearing him as like the
street level Thanos of the MCU what does
that really mean well this Wilson Fisk
is a guy who still has the criminal past
the one that we saw in the three seasons
of the Netflix daral shows since they've
been confirmed as Canon but F believes
he has been healed but really you should
say born again and the way that some
born- again Christians think that oh
just because I got baptized as an adult
means that hey I'm saved even though I
killed a bunch of people that's not the
case with all the Born Again Christians
I'm just saying some of them feel like
hey just because I dunk my head in some
water I'm a good person suddenly he may
think that that moment with Maya Lopez
washed away his past sins and has put
him now in his own mind on a kind of
moral Crusade this would actually be
similar to how the Russo Brothers
describ Thanos in Infinity War I think
it's why people are calling Wilson Fisk
the street level Thanos because remember
in the infinity War commentary the Russo
Brothers talked about how Thanos is a
True Believer on a kind of sacred Quest
and that's why he takes his armor off
for Infinity war that armor represents
his past as a conqueror and now he has
adopted kind of a a religious monk Quest
a gentler more decisive yet still
coldblooded approach like he's
essentially an executioner administering
Justice or like that priest and King of
the Hill you know via condos and I think
part of fisk's plan is to fight this
battle with a reality that he can
control and manipulate that's why the
metaverse is coming up in Eko Wilson
Fisk used more technological gadgetry
than we have ever seen him used before
it's specifically a contact lens that
projects augmented reality arms over his
body to discreetly translate his words
into ASL for Maya so that no one else
can snoop we've actually mentioned
before that this feels a lot like Tony
Stark's Edith glasses this is a very
interesting technology if this like were
to roll out on a consumer scale it could
be quite a game changer to the Society
of the MCU like suddenly the whole
populace could be influenced by a kind
of objective reality to the same extent
that team Mysterio and Spider-Man far
from home was able to do but instead of
holograms from invisible drones this
would be a reality coded into the
contact lenses inside your eyelids I
have speculated that Wilson Fisk and his
operatives have gone in together to take
over Avengers Tower and turn it into
Fisk Tower and those remaining heads
that he referred to could be referring
to other members of an intelligencia a
real intelligencia who runs the fake
goofy website those heads could include
Sharon Carter xiling of the 10 Rings
samel Sterns but by talking about
remaining heads doesn't that kind of
sound like Hydra to you I left out the
existing digital threats of the MCU
lingering danger of AI that was never
truly snuffed Zola and the factions of
Hydra that he continues to represent and
Ultron because I've never truly believed
he's fully gone I mean who would need a
physical body when mayor Fisk has flesh
in Spades the more people Fisk can
convince to plug into his digital
reality that he creates manipulates the
more vulnerable people would be to
things like Zola and Ultron so Captain
America Brave New World is coming
February 14th 2025 for now at least and
even if it gets delayed I think it's
going to be the first MCU title of the
year 2025 even before Daredevil Born
Again comes out so while I think
president Thaddius Ross and his Red Hulk
plot will be the primary conflict of
Captain America 4 because they have
Harrison Ford for this movie and that's
probably the most cinematic thing to do
with the character of thus Ross some of
these current rewrites I think are
designed to play up the political
paranoia in the conspiracies to live up
to a title like Brave New World and I
think it's going to be a society fed by
Wilson fisk's political campaign to use
manipulated media to erase his criminal
backstory in the Public's eyes literally
in their eyes to create create a fake
news campaign that basically changes the
media record so that no one can find any
evidence of him being arrested and every
time you try to Google that your search
results are flooded with alternate news
sites talking about how great Wilson
Fisk is and while you would think the
public would be able to see through that
think about this public they've
been traumatized by blips by Doctor
Strange spells that they don't
technically know about by celestials
they don't know what to believe so I
think Fisk is going to use this to
overturn the political status quo he's
going to rise in popularity and he's
going to threaten the power of the White
House and that could be what Drive a
president Ross into an insane strongman
move so in summary serpent Society out
sorry Seth Rollins meanwhile mayor and
future presidential candidate Wilson
Fisk digitally manipulated metaverse is
in and potentially Zola and Ultron back
too but I want to know your thoughts on
this theory in the comments below
support new rockstars by grabbing some
merch at nerd rot. shop subscribe to new
rockstars follow me at eaos thanks so
much for watching I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye
oh